the hot weather has now been deemed as
dangerous as this
a red weather warning last brought on by
storm eunice now for the first time a
heat wave is just as extreme as a
meteorologist it's possibly the most
remarkable weather forecast i've ever
seen to not just break the temperature
record in one or two spots but to see 40
degrees forecast in parts of the uk and
i understand how much these heat waves
affect people they affect people's
health they affect the infrastructure
and it's not just vulnerable people who
need to look out for fit and healthy
people can be affected by this level of
heat as well because of course in this
country we're not set up for these kinds
of temperatures and it's this inability
to cope that's impacting our everyday
lives the uk's health security agency
says this is a national emergency
schools are shutting offices are closing
for some it's a return to working from
home
for those that can't like ellie who
works in a hospital unions have called
for adjustments amid record-breaking
temperatures i mean i'm happy to go at
work but at least if we had some more
funds and more air conditioning it would
be easier for us and plus it's not good
for the patients because they are not
motivated to do therapy and they feel
like more dizzy they have more headaches
they feel most tired from hospitals to
homes britain's infrastructure is about
to be tested these temperatures can have
adverse health effects can lead to
increased water safety incidents power
cuts and travel delays this is the first
time the country is about to be
challenged on the way it copes with
extreme heat
the extreme weather is already impacting
vital deliveries
often the delivery
companies that are delivering our
medicines every day
they'll have cut offs so they have
temperatures in their van if it goes
above that 25 degrees
they have to go back and they can't
supply you
so
someone who might be expecting their
medication in the afternoon might have
to wait until the following morning if
we can't get hold of it
and for those who want to take advantage
of the exceptional heat comes a direct
warning recent research we've done two
thirds of children under the age of 18
when they drown they've been sighted
that they can swim but their swimming
ability just doesn't translate into cold
open water moving environments where
they can't see the bottom so we want
people to go places where there's
supervision if they cannot go somewhere
supervision in their local community
stay close to the edge and make sure
that somebody's watching you so that if
you get into trouble they can call help
on 999.
that reminder as we brace ourselves for
a long hot and potentially dangerous
summer
harinac sky news